so you mentioned that the part that you
got in the deuce was written
for you yeah he said he wrote a role
with me and mine yeah
how how did that wind up comparing to
joining the cast of judas and the black
messiah where shaka had you in mind for
the role of
deborah is it is it a different feeling
when you're starting a project when you
know
that the role was meant for you in that
way the blessing is that i didn't feel
any
pressure for that kind of thing like i
knew that i had been working
you know so long and so hard that uh
when i was in school and it was time to
like get an agent i would be like you
know what i'm just gonna focus on the
craft because
i love meryl streep right she transforms
in every single thing that she does and
i used to be like even if somebody
doesn't like
the particular movie that she does they
can't say she can't act
you will never be able to say that and
so i want to be like that
right so i'm thinking about that in
terms of how the craft
and so if david simon who's worked with
so many greats
sees this in me and says this is for you
if you want it
why would i question myself you know i'm
not gonna second guess what i'm doing
i'm just gonna continue to do if i
if i get a little self-conscious what
can i do i can go back to the drawing
board
journal as my characters because that's
what got me here put
put summarize each scene because that's
what got me here put a song to each
scene because that's what got me here
as long as i stay true to the work of it
then i don't have to so much be afraid
of
of living up to the occasion or or
perception that i've probably put on
somebody else about me that they're
probably not even thinking of
you know and so when shaka came to me
about that i was definitely flawed by
that one
it was so already so many greats
attached daniel was attached to it with
freaking ryan coogler was producing it
charles king i'm like
and there and he wants to get jesse
plemmons and he's saying this is for you
this is this is for you i was like oh
like oh my god so i wasn't so much
nervous i was just more honored
and like i felt seen sometimes you know
we're doing work for so long and
you could be looked over for a certain
role or be like why i don't understand
i'm working so hard i'm
showing this aspect of me i'm showing
this thing i'm really trying i'm trying
to do something different
is anybody seeing this and to know that
somebody was seeing me and that he had
seen me and show me a hero
so he knew about me for a long time
you